how good is this team Calvin how good is
this really very very very good first of
all I tell everyone this is no fluke
everybody thinks they arrived me a wave
right now they are surely legitimate and
when you start talking about the
upcoming playoffs and and of course the
Golden State's being the league of
frontrunners on paper the rock is right
now are the frontrunners on court that's
what I tell everyone mm-hmm and when it
comes down to it Calvin what makes this
team so good well first of all the
system you know the Rockets started off
the season with uh we're going to out
shoot everybody out score everyone and
as they went along then they started
drafted defensive players like PJ Tucker
to come into a system and boot a and
things of that nature so they put their
their tremendous offense with some
defensive players on the court that also
can shoot and their deepest improved so
much that now is hard to match up
against them and it's hardly different
plan oh absolutely
and what makes him a different player is
he's more confident in his teammates
when he field now but he doesn't have to
do it all by himself
the greatest move the Rockets made for
James Harden was cp3
Chris Paul why is that well first of all
now you can't double and triple team
James Harden team or because you've got
a future hall-of-famer on the other side
of that court and with that being said
if the right hand no gliches the left
hand will hmm Calvin Murphy Pro
Basketball Hall of Famer here on the
Rich Eisen show because the merit of
just a couple of years ago is that
Harden wasn't even really trying right
that there was something wrong with him
there in Houston and it just seems last
year he had a Hall of Fame I mean a an
MVP season if it wasn't for all the
triple doubles out of Oklahoma City and
now this year he's just taken it to a
whole different level
well you know when you start talking
about James Harden of the past you talk
about two different players James Harden
has always been a player since you've
been in the rocket uniform that has felt
that he had so much on his shoulders he
need to carry the whole franchise well
that's not his that's not his outlook
anymore
and with that being said you look at the
players they put around him any night
one of them can come up with a big game
and he recognizes that now so what he's
doing he's just free stroking there's no
real pressure on him anymore to take it
upon himself to lead this team to the
promised land he noticed now it's gonna
be a 15 man show and with that being
said if you look at his demeanor if you
look at his his body language game times
there's there's no urgency there's
nothing but let me stay within the
system the coach does a heck of a job
the entirety of a heck of a job with his
with his matchups up on game the game
the combinations he puts on the floor
and of course now James Harden is the
ace in the hole he does have to be the
whole show hmm Calvin Murphy joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show how do you
think they matchup against Golden State
seven-game series because let's just get
Brown a brass tacks that's what it looks
like it might have to come down to here
Calvin unfortunate that one of these
teams are gonna go home before the
finals because they're both in the West
which I think is unfortunate I think
when they cope with a new system in the
end the two best teams I'll end up being
the finals would be a better situation
for this for the NBA right now but but
the answer your question and not to skip
around it Golden State is not the team
that of course they're still a great
team but they're not the team they were
the last couple of years
one reason if people don't fear them
anymore you know and when I say that you
see against a team that you don't expect
to beat is worth from star five to eight
points game so now Golden State has got
to play chains and teams come Adam real
hard
well the Rockets feel that way also now
if you go back a few years if I could
skip a few years back during the time
when when the when the Lille had the
Bulls with Michael Jordan
and they were running ran shot through
the league the Rockets always matched up
well against him and the rocks were able
to beat them during the regular season
now with that being said of course
Jordan leaves Elijah waar becomes the
man they were in two championships and
people talk about well if Jordan was
there with the Rockets head one well my
answer said that question is still there
absolutely because of the massive
situations Golden State's have a great
defensive team the Rockets have a great
defensive and a good defensive team so
with that being said it overrides would
Golden State has done in the past look
everything is about perception and
everybody feels that great whole estate
is investable that's not the case
anymore they're a great team but they
are no longer invincible I can't wait I
hope they do face one another you know
you never know obviously but right now
looks like they're they're on a they're
on a on a collision course what Hardin
did to Wesley Johnson
Calvin does that does that ring a bell
anything that you've ever seen what's
the worst I guess ankle breaking in my
opinion of that I've seen hard do worse
things to people than that I actually
think the young man fell down he got the
feet twisted up and fell down so he was
all it went viral in it and and you know
everybody made such a big deal out of it
I didn't you know so but I've seen
Hardin heard some people's feelings in
the past what's the worst really what's
the worst feelings you've ever seen hurt
either from your playing days or viewing
days what's the worst you ever seen oh
goodness gracious like I can't answer
that question I've said I've seen some
I've seen some situations where you want
to go home and take the dog so I can't I
can't answer that question you know I've
seen some great ball handlers when you
go all the way back to the answer when
you're talking about Iverson and and
then when you you know of course James
Hart and then I've seen one of my
favorite players in in Mad Max who
played with the Rockets
during the next well do some things with
the ball in the past that that was
tremendous you know during my playing
time I had a little ball handling skills
and yes I did a couple of things to
people that they're still mad about so I
mean you answer that question okay well
you're also a nice guy I guess you don't
want to you don't want to go ahead and
say that you are you are the the
shortest player ever inducted in the
Basketball Hall of Fame at five foot
nine Calvin what do you think of Isaiah
Thomas's game and now that he's now
gotten on a couple of teams and maybe
perhaps another once his contract
expires here in Los Angeles what do you
what do you think of his future in this
league that you could see well you know
he's a tremendous player obviously you
know you know I'm not big on talking
about the size of a player I talk about
the ability and if the player size fits
the system he's in now the problem that
Isaiah has just gotten into is getting
caught on that trade with that trade
mill where they train you here there and
everywhere
and that hurts your ability to show your
ability when you get on a team and you
got to work your way into the system and
then you know next year you're someplace
else but as a pure talent he is he's
something special you know I've always
been big on left-handed players for some
reason because those days are always
leaving me Fitz and the team that beat
me from high school college and in the
pros had stars that were left-handed so
I don't know what it is from the fact of
the matter is he is a tremendous
ballplayer when he gets into a system
that fits what he does see all teams are
not for all players and and
unfortunately he got injured coming out
of Boston where he started getting his
reputation he got injured he goes to the
tabs which was a very very bad situation
for him because just just just the whole
situation wasn't going to work from my
opinion from the very beginning put him
behind the eight ball but once he gets
where he is going to be in their system
is made for him he's going to be an
all-star I'm not going to say a
superstar but he's gonna be an all-star
do you think he looks healthy to you I'm
sorry do you think he looks healthy
to you based on what you could have seen
of him ah I think he's out of shape I
don't think that that year off helped
them any I think he's still going to
work his way into shape one thing about
the average to small player they've got
to always be in tremendous shape to play
this game because they got to use their
attributes they got to use their speed
and their quickness now the one thing I
would like to see more of what he does
is to work on that that medium range
jump shot because one side the defense
very easily but taking the ball to the
basket it's going to get him hurt
occasion
I know you got yourself a big game
tonight Houston at Milwaukee on the
back-to-back you're watching something
potentially historic unfold love to have
you back on down the road as as things
get really really serious in the
playoffs
well the Rockets win it out before they
happen to be on this fun your show to
tell you I told you so okay my pleasure
that would be great thanks talent you
take care it's Calvin Murphy at Calvin
Murphy HOF the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience